let's go next to our caller from the
two-seven-zero area code caller from
two-seven-zero you're on go ahead
hi how's it going David it's going well
who's this this is clay two-seven-zero
is a Kentucky number but I'm actually
calling from Iowa all right what's on
your mind yeah I was calling I just
wanted to say first of all I'm a member
and a huge fan of the show and I was
actually just wondering if you could
give us an update on what's going on
with your patreon account and if you had
anything in mind like the Ginga thing to
kind of bring some of those patreon
supporters back yeah so we took a big
hit on patreon when patreon rolled out
this new fee structure which they
ultimately cancelled actually but we
lost about a hundred and fifty patrons
so the big thing we've got going on
right now is we're trying to get to 2250
2250 patrons and then we'll do this
critical thinking miniseries which i
think is just going to be awesome
but in terms of a game we've thought of
a few things we don't want to just
replay Jenga and the Jenga thing is
still on on the desk next to me by the
way we thought about blowing up a
balloon one pump for each donation until
it popped but the logistics of it the
balloon deflates overnight so that's not
working we've had the idea of doing
something magnet related where we hang
something with magnets and eventually it
becomes more and more weighed down and
eventually the magnet won't hold anymore
but the logistics of securing something
from the ceiling have been difficult so
we I don't know yet what we're gonna do
but I do want to do something yeah yeah
cool well I look forward to it and I
just wanted to thank you guys for the
awesome job you do you and Pat and
everyone involved and I enjoyed the show
all right thanks very much appreciate
the call from clay always good to hear
from clay